My man, Pharmacist Ben.
>> What's up, AJ?
>> How are you?
>> Please, someone tell me I have to talk
into the microphone.
>> I know, you sound like you're in a space
shuttle.
>> Who said make sure you talk into the
microphone?
>> It's like T minus one.
>> What's going on, buddy? How you doing?
>> How are you, man?
>> All right.
>> And I know
>> up there. I got to fly out early in the
AM.
>> Yeah, I know. And I
I appreciate you making
um
I appreciate you making the time to do
the show cuz I know how busy
>> AJ, I don't do it for you. I do it for
the people.
For the people.
>> I'm showing appreciation for the people
because I do I get tons of texts and
when's the show starting? Where we at?
What's going on? Where's Ben?
>> All right.
>> So, I am thanking you for that. And cuz
I unlike everybody else, I do know how
busy your schedule actually is.
And welcome to another Pharmacist Ben's
Bites or
rootnotfruit.com.
Uh everybody check out that site is very
helpful.
Uh triangleofdisease.com
please get there. Pharmacist Ben our
title today
>> Yeah.
>> is
PCS is now P O P M O S.
>> Yeah, I thought that was cute. I thought
that was really cute. What do what does
it stand for?
>> It stands for
you know it they're talking about the
lymph now as opposed to
>> Right, it doesn't say say what the PCM
the whole thing stands for the whole the
whole acronym.
>> It stands
for
polyendocrine metabolic ovarian
syndrome.
>> Okay.
So, it sounds scary, right? Oh my god.
Uh polymetabolic endocrine ovarian
syndrome or polyendocrine metabolic
ovarian syndrome. Oh my god. What do I
have? Well, really what they're just
trying to tell you they used to say
called polycystic
ovarian syndrome meaning you have lots
of cysts, right?
Polycyst. Now they call it poly
metabolic
endocrine
ovarian syndrome.
Right? So, they stuck in What did they
stick in there?
Metabolic. Metabolic and endocrine,
right? So, it went from just cysts,
right?
To metabolic and endocrine. Why?
Because cysts affect everything.
The cysts make endocrine hormones which
affects your metabolism. It's just
gibberish.
It's everything disease.
It's everything. Everything is
everything.
Don't You don't have to worry about the
specifics.
You know, in the old days they used to
focus on specific organs before we
understood the body was a whole system
where everything's interactive,
everything's connected.
And so when you have a system, one of
the hallmarks of a system is there's
going to be leverage points or choke
points.
All systems have choke points.
That is points in the system that
control everything else or a lot of
other things. If you want to get healthy
in a system, if you want to make a
system healthy, your power comes at the
leverage points, the choke points. Are
you with me? The bottlenecks.
Those are the things that cause the
problems. It's so you have a a bunch of
pieces. Well, let me Let's me give you
an example here.
Um Well, like the class example is
digestive the the body. The biological
system has choke points.
Right? The only major choke points, the
only choke points you have to concern
yourself with are the digestive system,
the blood sugar system,
and the adrenal thyroid link or the
adrenal thyroid complex. What do we call
that?
>> Triangle of disease.
>> Bingo. That's the choke The reason those
three points are so fundamental is
because those are the choke points that
control everything else. Primarily the
digestive system, but also the the
metabolic system. So, PCOS is like
everything else or piece now
P What do they call it? PC MEO No,
PMEOs.
>> PM PMOS, yes.
>> PMOS or PMEOs? Polymetabolic endocrine
Polymetabolic endocrine ovarian
syndrome.
>> Well,
polyendocrine metabolic ovarian
syndrome.
>> Right. They took out the cystic and they
changed it to metabolic and ovarian.
>> Mhm.
>> And or metabolic and endocrine. Why?
Because the cyst changed the metabolism
and the endocrine system. So, they
changed the C for the ME. It's the same
same stuff.
Work on your digestive system.
Particularly on the sugar
and around food toxins or leaky gut.
That's it. Then you take then you
stabilize the blood sugar.
That's it. That's how you deal with
PCOS. Now, if you want to throw in
something else, you make your hormones
in the adrenal glands The adrenal glands
make hormones, I should say. And so,
work on adrenal health, too. Calm the
body down. But But it'll naturally calm
down once you take care of your
hypoglycemia,
your blood sugar issues, and your
inflammatory the inflammatory um
molecules that are getting into the
bloodstream. That's why I always say the
third point is like
you know, you don't have to worry as
much as as the first two points, which
is why we focus on the plane or the two
points at the bottom of the triangle.
Listen.
What is the What is the major disease
that smart people suffer from?
>> Overthinkitis.
>> Don't overthink.
Don't overthink. And if you have an
ovarian problem, you don't go
necessarily have to go to the OB/GYN.
And you might have got a digestive
problem, you go to the GI doctor and a
or a car heart problem, you go to the
cardiologist and a
brain problem, you go to the
neurologist. It's a system.
Focus on the choke points.
Digestion, blood sugar. That's
metabolic. PCOS is is a classic
digestive
and a blood sugar condition.
>> You know, in the article it mentioned
that they they changed it in their
opinion because
uh
the syndrome, as you said, many things
occurring,
uh
didn't always include cysts.
But people still had the issue.
Um
>> Oh, I see. Okay, I see what you're
saying. All right, so yeah, you don't So
you That's why you don't necessarily
need cysts because you could just have
an you could just have an ovarian
condition.
Cysts are just one of the one of the
things that can happen. That's true.
>> And and and that's why they changed it.
>> or P or
P E M O S or P M E O S is a I mean,
you're P M E O S.
>> There's no E in it. P M O S.
>> Oh, they're not calling it P a metabolic
endocrine. Okay. So, poly
>> polyendocrine
metabolic
>> So, P E M S or P M O S.
>> But yeah, P M, they're not
>> Uh-huh. All right. There is a major
major major major link between the P
between PCOS or whatever you want to
call it now and
the intestine and dysbiosis and a leaky
gut. Major.
And intestine there's a major relation
between intestinal uh distress uh
distress or distress and um insulin
resistance.
And insulin resistance
is involved with male hormones as a
major male hormones are also involved in
this condition.
You can't
you don't want to go crazy trying to
trying to deal with every single link.
Digestion, blood sugar. Why is that
complex? Why is this Is it because we
don't want to mess around with it? It
sounds too simple.
>> People don't want to stop eating.
>> All right. It's interesting because both
digestion and blood sugar involve
eating.
And when you think about what we eat, I
mean you know, obviously we're going to
have problems. So that's that's that on
on PCOS.
>> And you know
uh
On a on a on a different topic, I got a
woman who uh is in the uh
in the doctor's now
and Keely and I talked to her yesterday
and I talk to her almost every day,
multiple times day and um
she's she's got some leg swelling.
Uh the doctor said that she had some
potential
uh congestive heart failure.
>> How old?
>> She's
62. Somewhere, you know, younger young.
>> Young.
>> Uh
and um
but very stressed out. You know, comes
from an Eastern Bloc country and you
know, they have that real um
you know, elevated uh conversation style
and um
you know, always seems to be stressed
out.
And uh
dealing with back pain and vertebrae and
you know, it's just these things uh
went to the chiropractor earlier today.
I had advised, you know, she should
probably just rest, but went to the
chiropractor
and the chiropractor says she's out of
alignment, totally out of alignment, so
did whatever
chiropractors do
and then, you know, I guess
suffered so much that you know, her
family forced her to go to the
emergency room or to the doctor, etc.
And um
you know, it's really hard to deal with
uh folks
whose
expectation is that they will resolve
their issues overnight.
Uh had been doing pretty good before she
had gotten some
um
dental work done and they gave her a
couple of injections
for I guess to numb before they were
pulling out the teeth.
And after that point, she she started
really suffering.
Um
so I'm mentioning this
partially for an analysis. I mean, I
didn't really give you much to go on,
but
uh also just to
kind of
highlight what I think you know,
um
relaxation
needs to be a part of people's
>> Why where where is where does relaxation
meet
Where does where do relaxation
strategies meet meet biology?
What part of the body?
>> Uh the nervous system?
>> Bingo.
So, relaxation
impacts the body via the nervous system.
Right? But you got two nervous systems.
Right? So, which nervous system does
relaxation interact
interface with the body?
>> Parasympathetic?
>> Correct.
That's why relaxation is so important
because all healing is in the realm of
the parasympathetic nervous system.
All illness or degeneration is in the
realm of the sympathetic nervous system.
So the parasympathetic is your your uh
your building nervous system, your
anti-inflammatory, your healing nervous
system. The sympathetic nervous system
is your emergency nervous system.
The sympathetic nervous system is
important cuz you got to deal with
emergencies.
But in our culture today, the
sympathetic nervous system is not only
overloaded,
but it's overloaded below threshold.
That's a very important point.
Because if you get overloaded to the
point of um
something happening,
you'll be able to create a change.
You'll be able to
If you know if you get If you If you're
If a lion is chasing you,
you'll know to run away from the lion.
But if you're eating the wrong kinds of
food and it's drip drip drip activating
your nerve sympathetic nervous system,
you're not going to know. It's drip drip
drip. And that's the kind of stress we
suffer from in this culture. It's not
the kind of stress that kills us or that
makes us run. It's the kind of stress
that just kind of eats at us over time
gradually.
Uh Thoreau said in the eight in the 19th
uh in the 19th century,
"Men live lives of quiet desperation."
Mhm. And that's how we live. We just
deal with things and we suppress things.
It's not like we have massive
emergencies. That book Why Zebras Don't
Get Ulcers by Robert Sapolsky says that
zebras don't get ulcers because
they don't have drip drip drip stress.
They have emergency stress.
The kind of stress that you makes you
run or die.
So when a when a zebra is under stress,
it either gets away from the stress, so
it lives,
or it um
it doesn't get away from the stress and
it dies.
Either way, the situation's resolved.
In our culture today, our situation
isn't resolved. It's just drip drip drip
stress and we don't notice it until a
symptom appears.
And then a symptom appears and because
we haven't linked it to this drip drip
drip stress, we don't know what to do.
So, activating the relaxation nervous
system is critical, not just for
reversing chronic degenerative disease,
not just for preventing chronic
degenerative disease, but for quality of
life.
Do you know a Blaise Pascal was a famous
You've heard of Blaise Pascal, famous
mathematician and philosopher. He said
the hardest thing for a man to do and
and these all these people talk about
men, but they meant men and women. They
weren't talking about men. Uh he said
the hardest thing for a man to do is sit
in a room all by himself and doing
nothing.
You imagine how hard that would be to
sit by yourself and do nothing? Doesn't
sound like it'd be hard.
Right?
>> Sit around and do nothing.
Yeah, he says.
>> I got to build a website.
>> Yeah, you got to do stuff, right? But
sitting there and doing nothing is a
wonderful way to activate the relaxation
response.
To calm the body down, to tell the body
to stand down. People can't do that. So,
that's why insomnia is such a problem.
Our mind goes crazy. Learning to take
care Learning Learning the mind, man.
It's about the mind.
The body is secondary to the mind.
Although it's bidirectional, I would
say. They both interact with each other,
but
mind power.
Focus on your mind. What What Think
about all our problems that are related
to our mind.
Right?
Aren't you doing
>> False evidence appearing real?
>> False evidence appearing real and and
imagination
catastrophizing and you know, what can
go wrong and what's going to happen to
me and uh fear of death and all There's
all kinds of things.
>> The light bill.
>> The light bill, right? The rent, all
that stuff, your kids.
Um but here's something Here's an
interesting question. Considering the
mind is so so important,
what is the mind?
Right?
>> Right.
>> Right. I know, right?
Right?
Clearly it's important, but what the
heck is it? You know, but these are
important questions that transcend the
healthy start pack.
But we're here to talk about the healthy
start pack. Your point your point is
well taken that you got to get the mind
under control. You got to activate the
parasympathetic nervous system. You got
to learn to relax. I like I like what
the you know, the Bible says
and the Bible says
um Jesus says you have to be saved. Or I
don't you know you know if that's in the
Bible, but that's Christian dogma. You
have to be saved, right?
>> Mhm.
>> It's really you have to be safe.
>> Not that you have to be saved. You have
to feel safe. You have to feel
comfortable in the world. You have to
feel okay. You have to be okay in the
world, okay in your body, okay with
yourself.
That's the most important thing is just
to be okay, to be all right. And
ironically
we're always okay in the moment. Like
right now you have everything you need.
And you're never okay. You're going to
die. You know, you're on the way to
death and and demise. So get get over
it. You know, we're missing our lives.
But I don't want to talk about that. I
want to talk about the healthy start
pack. I want to talk about nutritional
supplementation. And
>> And by the way
the body will go into duress mode or
cells will go into duress mode when they
don't have raw materials. When they
don't have resources. The lack of
resources, nutritional resources in
terms of physiology, oxygen, lack of
oxygen, those will cause the body to go
into stress mode, into into a
sympathetic nervous system activation.
So that's why muscle relaxant relaxation
is so important for things like high
blood pressure or arthritis or chronic
pain or digestive health issues.
Learning to activate the parasympathetic
nervous system is critical.
All of that. Disease is disease.
You're out of ease.
Disease is when you're out of ease.
That's sympathetic. Ease is
parasympathetic. Disease to ease. That's
the that's the direction you want to
take. All right, but I got to go here in
a few minutes. So let's get get some
questions.
>> Well, before we get questions, the
second por- the second portion of our
title dealt with
>> Tattoos. The tattoos.
>> tattoos and lymphoma
>> I know. Well, what do you think happens
when you inject ink into your into your
body into your circular into your
through your skin?
Of course, you're going to run risks of
lymphatic problems. Lymphoma is an
immune Lymphoma is a cancer of the
immune system.
So, you know, I mean, it's crazy to
First of all, I never under- Do you have
any tattoos?
>> Not a not a one.
>> I don't I don't have any tat- I never
understood the whole thing with tattoos,
but you know,
maybe you like them, they're pretty,
they're artistic, that's fine, but
they're not good for you from a health
perspective. You're putting ink in your
body.
Toxic ink.
>> I I hung out at a tattoo shop and
you know, I actually saw Paris Jackson
get a tattoo once.
>> You really did? In person?
>> Yeah, I mean, I was there, yeah.
>> Was she in New York? Paris Jackson was
in New York?
>> She was hanging out in New York, yeah.
>> Did you just run into her or you knew
her?
>> Well, no, she came to the tattoo shop.
>> Were you working in the tattoo shop?
>> I was hanging out at the tattoo shop.
>> Oh, you hang And she walked in randomly?
>> She she Well, maybe she knew one of the
tattoo artists prior, but it was one of
the ones on West 4th Street that stayed
open late at the time.
>> How old was she?
>> Yeah, she was she was
not mature.
>> She was like a
kid?
>> She So, let's say this was
less than 10 years ago.
And she was She was cute.
Now, she's stunning.
>> Paris Jackson.
>> Have you ever seen her?
>> I haven't, no. No, I
I can't believe You know, not long ago
Michael Jackson die?
>> I know, it's been a while, right?
>> It's crazy, right? 2009.
>> Oh, man, has it been that long?
>> Can you believe it?
>> Yeah, that's that's crazy.
>> That's 17 years 17 years ago he's been
gone.
>> Yeah, Emprince, but you know, what they
said was there were 316 pairs of twins
that they analyzed and one set of twin
one half of the twins did not get the
tattoo and the other half of the twin
get got the tattoo and they got a 62%
increase in the probability of
getting a lymphoma.
>> Well, that makes perfect sense.
I mean, you're injecting ink into your
body.
I don't know enough about tattoos to
know how far the ink goes, but I can't
imagine it doesn't that it doesn't get
somehow into the circulatory system into
the lymph
on some level and it activates an immune
response.
>> Mhm.
>> It's ink. It's in your body.
>> You know, ink is not supposed to be in
your body. I don't even know what the
ink is to tell you the truth.
But it's permanent, so it must be
something that's, you know, it doesn't
wash off. So, it's it's got to be
something sticky.
>> And I guess there's no way to to do a
vitamin C tattoo, right? So,
they couldn't inject
>> all doing tattoos, you want to make sure
you're doing a lot of nutrients. You
know, that gets me that reminds me of
this thing that not that it reminds me,
but it makes me think of um
this guy I was just I did a Zoom call
with Bronnie just before this, right?
And so, this guy comes on and he says um
he says soot is if somebody's sending
soot. Soot is a major carcinogen. Major.
In fact, cancer was really discovered in
soot as a reaction to soot uh by chimney
sweep. By They used to send little kids
in in in London in England during the
Industrial Revolution, they would send
little kids to clean chimneys.
That was their job and the little kids
would get testicular cancer.
And that soot was one of the first
places was one of the first
first places they noticed carcinogens.
So, yes, if you're putting soot in your
blood, that's not a good thing. So,
anyway, I did this I was on this Zoom
call with Bronnie and this guy comes on
and he says
um
he says the shingles vaccine uh it
cuts Alzheimer's disease incidence of
Alzheimer's disease. He said he read it.
And I'm okay, fine.
And you think about it, how would that
even happen? Well, it turns out that if
you go online and you look it up, you'll
see that there are there's studies
that show that
>> Five people?
>> No, there are studies, but but what they
don't filter for is how do you know that
people get the shingles vaccine also
maybe they supplement also, or maybe
they pay more attention to their health,
or maybe they
uh are more cognizant of Alzheimer's
disease. You don't know. These are
epidemiological studies where they just
have questionnaires. They're not causal.
You can't prove things are causal. So,
you know, when you talk about things
like um
like tattoos and and sticking ink in
your blood, you just got to use your
logic. Whether or not, you know, it's
proven that ink that the that uh
people have ta- who people get tattoos
at are at higher risk for cancer,
we don't know that definitively, but
just use your logic. You're putting a
toxin into your system. That is how
cells get disturbed. That's how
chemistry gets disturbed. So, you can't
You just got to You got to work with
mechanisms. You got to work with logic.
If you have If you have a a toxic
substance and you put in your blood,
yes, there's or you put it in your into
your circulatory system, yes, the
chances are good that you're going to
disturb your circu- your immune system
and you could get cancer. It's just
logic. Anyway, let's get a couple
questions cuz I got I got to go.
>> I don't know if we want to I don't know
if you want to approach this question.
Uh Bernadette saying upset friend's
daughter age 15 wants to be male. Any
advice?
>> You know, that whole transgender thing,
it's more political than anything else.
Um
the girl wants to be a boy.
You know,
that's that's not really a nutritional
thing. Although, I think Dr. Wallach
used to say it was a nutritional thing.
>> Dr. Wallach Dr. Wallach said they're not
getting lithium.
>> Lith- Is that what he said?
>> Mhm. Or minerals, but one being lithium.
>> Okay.
Yeah, I I don't know if that's a
nutritional thing. It's more
psychological thing.
I I think it's interesting how when I
was growing up the transgender was
really weird. I mean, I never heard of
it even. Did you when you were growing
up or hear ever hear transgender?
>> Mhm. Not transgender cuz they weren't
didn't have the surgery and technology,
but it did there were some kids that I
know that, you know, dressed dressed
differently.
>> Yeah, I I never It's a It seems to be a
modern thing. I don't have any idea, but
I do know that there are hormone
disruptors that are we're immersed in in
our culture.
And gender is largely determined or at
least affected, if not determined,
affected by hormones.
>> There's something about tadpoles and
some frogs that
>> Yeah, that's what, you know, Alex Jones,
he was, you know, in his own Alex Jones
way, "Oh, they're making the
They're making the frogs gay." And
everybody
And everybody got all mad. Yeah, "Oh,
they're They're going to MAKE THE FROGS
GAY."
AND EVERYBODY ALL MADE FUN of him, but
he was right. They're not making, you
know, the frogs He He was just joking,
you know, that's how he is. But he But
his point was is that animals like
tadpoles are becoming hermaphroditic.
They're developing male and sex male and
female sexual characteristics. So, um
yeah, it could be what's in the water.
It could easily be cuz there's there's
hormone disruptors everywhere. They call
them endocrine disruptors, hormone
disruptors. And they change They change
the way hormones They change the way the
body responds to hormones.
So, I don't really transgender, I you
know, I I think people should do
whatever they want to do. Kids it's a
little different, you know, cuz they're
kids. You don't necessarily want to do,
you know, let your kid do whatever he
wants to do, but people should be
whatever gender they want to be. I don't
I don't have a problem
>> Yeah, I I agree with you, but there's a
good number of people who regretted
having surgeries.
>> That's why you don't want kids to do it
cuz they're too young to make their own
decisions. But yeah, if you
you know, if somebody really feels like
they want to um
be a different gender, more power to
them. Be whatever gender you want to be.
I don't I don't have an issue with that.
>> You're really saying
>> Colorado, by the way, was one of the
first places where these exper- these
not exper- but surgical procedures took
place
in Trinidad, I think it was. Trinidad,
Colorado, I'm pretty sure. And when I
was a starting pharmacy school, I used
to have to drive to people's homes to
deliver hormones. Cuz they were going to
Trinidad, and they were going to have
not homes but hotels. They were staying
in Colorado and they needed hormones
because they were going into surgery.
So, they used to pretreat with hormones.
So, I got to meet a lot of transgender
people, people who were about to have
the surgical procedure.
And they're real they're really
beautiful people. They're good people.
Yeah, they're really I enjoyed
>> But I didn't I didn't know that I didn't
know that you were a part of the
movement. I didn't know that.
>> I wasn't a necessary part of the
movement, but I I
Yeah, I was kind of facilitating with
hormones as a pharmacist. But I got to
know them and I got to talk to them and
they were they were all really, really
nice, kind people.
Very gentle,
you know, very very sensitive people.
So, whatever gender you want, I don't
have a I don't have a problem with that,
but kids are different. So, somebody's
asked about Lyme disease.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, there's two kinds of Lyme
disease Well, there's one kind of Lyme
disease, but there's two guises of it.
One is Lyme disease, which is an
infection, you take antibiotics and it's
gone. The other is chronic Lyme disease.
That doesn't go away.
Whenever you have a chronic condition
that does not go away, even though it
should, like an infection, like COVID,
long COVID, or
a chronic Lyme,
what part of the body do you think is
always going to be implicated?
>> Could it be the digestive system?
>> The intestine, always. Always. And
people have chronic Lyme disease have
high levels of LPSs, endotoxins,
histamines. These are all things that
get secreted into the blood through a
leaky gut.
It's a gut problem. Same with long
COVID.
Okay? Anytime you have a condition that
does not reverse itself when it's
supposed to, such as a chronic
degenerative disease or
a long infection that should resolve and
it doesn't, suspect
immune activation through the through a
leaky gut into the blood. Work on
digestive health. That's my suggestions.
And and and if you keep going to
doctors, they're never going to tell you
this. They don't know.
But get online and just look it up.
Get online right now and look up chronic
Lyme and endotoxins.
Or chronic Lyme and LPS.
Or chronic Lyme and um leaky gut. What
does this What does this say?
>> Uh I I don't have that, but what I what
I did what I did pull up was your gut
immune barrier.
>> Not mine. Look up chronic Lyme and
endotoxins.
Or LPS.
>> Okay, so it says
"Pharmacist Ben is right. It says
uh unique expression of chronic Lyme
disease and Jarisch- It's believed that
the result of endotoxins released from
the spirochete
>> Those are bacteria
in the gut.
>> or possibly a cytokine-mediated
response."
>> It's I You don't need I don't need the
internet to prove it. I know it because
it's logic, but I just want to show you.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay? That I'm not the
You don't need the proof, you just have
to understand how the body works.
That's how toxins get into the system.
That's how the immune system becomes
compromised. Unless you inject. And
that's why you got to be careful about
injecting.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay?
And then do your do the research on
you'll see.
>> Yeah, no. I mean
Uh, you you you've not steered me wrong.
Uh, Julie, if you need some help, uh,
you know, what I what I would suggest is
that you come to if you cuz Pharmacist
Ben mentioned that he wanted you to, um,
work on a person's gut, you might want
to come here to rootnotfruit.com and see
the gut immune repair protocol.
And we got the I26, we got the nightly
essence, we got the ultimate enzymes,
and the Z radical.
Uh, and that is to be worked with the
healthy body start pack. So, um, that is
something that you can do, and you can
also call us at 855-949-3377.
That is where this person is calling
now. They called four times, so they
must have a question that they wanted to
ask us on air,
uh, but I was unable to answer because
you were
in the midst of describing something
else. So, um,
that is the case, but there's Pharmacist
Ben's beautiful face, and uh, you can
come here and see, uh,
some of the protocols. We got the gut
immune repair, got the metabolic reset,
and we have the skyscraper protocol. So,
come to the site, and you can see some
of the things that are going to be very
helpful for you and your family and
friends, and never forget to go to
triangle of disease to kind of
understand what Pharmacist Ben,
uh, mentioned.
Uh, he talked about,
uh, the two points of the triangle, the
blo
digestive system, and the blood sugar
system being very important for all
chronic disease. So, come here to this
site, and you can learn more, get more
information, and help you and your
friends and family
to be
>> we need distributors.
We'll teach you everything you want to
know about nutrition and the Youngevity
products and how to help your friends
and family and loved ones and strangers
and people in your life. We'll help you
Everything's reversible, you guys.
Everything is reversible. Everything in
the way of chronic degenerative disease,
even stage four cancer,
which is a little trickier, but it's
still reversible. The spontaneous
remissions occur all the time. So,
please understand with your chronic
degenerative disease, if you're dealing
with a chronic degenerative disease, it
is reversible. But, what's the
definition of insanity?
Doing the same thing over and over again
and expecting different results. So, you
got to do things differently. We can
teach you how to do that and we can
teach you how to teach others to do
that.
Okay, AJ. I got to motivate. Have a
beautiful, wonderful day or night and I
will talk to you next next Friday.
>> Fly safely.
>> Thank you, buddy. Bye.
>> Thank you.
>> In this generated video, a single red
blood cell slowly deflates and loses its
color in a dark void. This is the visual
reality of anemia, a condition where the
blood lacks the healthy cells needed to
transport oxygen.
Every day, millions dutifully swallow
iron supplements to combat this, yet
their blood work remains unchanged.
We often blame the supplement's quality
or the brand's strength, but the true
flaw lies within the body's internal
delivery system.
Swallowing a mineral is merely the first
step. It does not guarantee your body
will actually absorb it. If the
physiological pipeline is blocked, the
raw material is useless.
Resolving chronic anemia requires a
structural mission to unblock three
specific anatomical bottlenecks, a goal
that remains out of reach by simply
increasing the daily dosage. The journey
begins at the stomach, the first
critical barrier. To break down raw
iron, the stomach must maintain an
intensely corrosive environment with a
pH level between 1 and 2. pH is a scale
used to specify the acidity or basicity
of an aqueous solution.
Manufacturing this hydrochloric battery
acid requires a steady supply of
chloride, the essential raw material the
body uses to fuel digestion.
This historic photograph shows workers
mining raw salt deep underground.
Historically, the body relied on sodium
chloride to produce digestive acids.
However, modern medically recommended
low-salt diets can inadvertently starve
the stomach of this critical building
block. Without adequate chloride, acid
production drops. The iron capsule
remains intact, passing through the
stomach without ever being dissolved or
utilized. Supplementing iron while
simultaneously restricting salt creates
a biochemical stalemate. The body lacks
the tools to process the very nutrients
it needs. If the iron manages to
dissolve, it reaches the small
intestine. This is the primary site
where minerals cross the final barrier
into the bloodstream. This microscopic
image shows healthy intestinal villi.
These are tiny finger-like structures
that act like an absorbent shag rug,
maximizing the surface area available to
capture nutrients. This historic
photograph captures workers threshing
wheat in the field. Modern wheat,
barley, rye, and oats all contain
gluten, a protein that can act as a
contact toxin for sensitive intestinal
tissues. Upon contact with gluten, these
delicate villi swell up, suffocating
their internal blood supply. Eventually,
they die off, leaving behind restrictive
scar tissue.
This animated diagram illustrates the
physical damage. The complex folded
surface on the left flattens into the
smooth line on the right, causing the
absorptive surface area to plummet by
98%. The intestine transforms into a
non-absorbent plastic tube. Once the gut
becomes a smooth tube, systemic
malnutrition is inevitable. At this
stage, no amount of oral iron can
penetrate the scarred barrier.
This microscopic image shows the bone
marrow matrix located deep within the
skeletal system.
This is the final destination for
successfully absorbed iron.
By focusing on the dense clusters of
purple stained cells, we can see the
body's active manufacturing zones.
The marrow is a high-speed factory, and
iron is only one of the materials
required to build a red blood cell.
To keep the assembly line moving, the
body requires cofactors, helper
nutrients like copper, zinc, and vitamin
B12.
These work alongside the foundational 90
essential nutrients to complete the
synthesis of blood.
If the factory lacks structural
materials like collagen or is missing
one minor cofactor, production halts.
The machinery remains idle despite the
presence of iron.
Chronic anemia is frequently the signal
of a total factory failure in the marrow
caused by these missing cofactors rather
than a simple iron deficit. Clearing
these bottlenecks requires a road map to
repair the anatomy and restore the
body's natural production. Step one is
the immediate elimination of all dietary
gluten. This stops the ongoing scarring
and allows the delicate intestinal villi
to slowly regrow their vital absorptive
texture. Step two focuses on the
stomach. Reintroducing salt to taste and
using digestive enzyme supplements helps
restore the corrosive environment needed
to dissolve minerals effectively.
Next, flood the system with the 90
essential nutrients, specifically copper
alongside collagen and MSM. MSM is a
naturally occurring sulfur compound the
body uses to provide structural
scaffolding for tissues. Step five
utilizes highly bioavailable liquid
mineral supplements. These bypass many
digestive hurdles to ensure the factory
in the bone marrow finally receives its
missing components. Chronic anemia is a
mechanical failure, not a permanent
genetic sentence.
By finally unblocking the supply chain,
you give your body the exact tools it
needs to rebuild itself.
>> All right, folks. So, um
you know, because Pharmacist Ben had to
uh depart a bit early today,
I am uh attempting to upload a new video
that we're going to premiere together
uh as soon as it is done processing. It
may take another couple minutes or so.
If folks have any uh
commentary,
I do want to thank you all for tuning
in. Becky, uh it will be amazing to have
you as part of the team and helping your
community.
And uh Bruce, as usual, uh thank you for
being
uh such a good a big part of what we do.
And uh let's see who else we got here.
We have Victor, of course, and
Bernadette.
Uh thank you for being here. Please, if
you are out there on any of the
platforms, just send us a little note.
Tell us where you are watching
from.
And Julie, thank you very much for your
question earlier.
Uh if you're watching on a platform
still, please let us know where you are
tuning in from
uh cuz we like to know where folks are
watching from. It'll be another minute
or so
and I'll be able to premiere
our new video. Uh, any uh, questions or
commentary
in the chats. Let's see. I don't see
any questions or commentary in the
chats. So, while
uh, the video is being uploaded, I'm
going to play a portion of another one
of our videos, but do stay tuned because
uh, I have a very uh, brand new,
never-seen-before video coming out. But,
first we're going to watch this one,
which we played last week.
>> You survived cancer, but the treatments
that saved your life often leave the
body in a state of extreme physical
trauma. You may find yourself dealing
with shedding tissue, exposed nerve
endings, and constant pain. Standard
pharmaceutical relief frequently fails
in these cases because the core issue is
structural. Your connective tissue
matrix, the biological womb where your
cells live, has physically dissolved.
Healing this environment is a mechanical
process. It requires rebuilding the
matrix from the ground up using specific
raw materials. By following a strict
five-step recipe, you can provide the
body with the components needed to patch
raw nerve endings and reconstruct your
cellular matrix. Step one is vitamin C.
This nutrient acts as the absolute
biological rate limiter for tissue
creation, meaning your body is
physically unable to manufacture new
connective tissue without it. In cases
of extreme post-cancer tissue trauma,
standard oral doses are generally
insufficient to meet the body's repair
demands. Intravenous vitamin C allows
for much higher concentrations to reach
the matrix, where it serves as a primary
anti-inflammatory and natural pain
reliever. Step two involves
polysaccharides.
The matrix is a wet environment that
requires specific biological mush to
maintain its structure. You can source
these materials from fucoidan Z, algae,
aloe vera, and fresh vegetable juices.
These polysaccharides act as sticky
electromagnetic seeds. They bind with
water to create a protective barrier
that patches up raw exposed nerve
endings. Combining the rate-limiting
power of vitamin C with these
electromagnetic seeds creates the
foundational environment necessary to
sustain new cellular life. Step three is
the scaffolding. Your body cannot
synthesize new tissue out of thin air.
It requires heavy structural rebar to
replace what was shredded. To saturate
the system, it needs specific structural
elements: collagen peptides,
high-quality whey protein, and
specialized gluco gel capsules. Treat
this post-cancer matrix damage with the
same aggressive structural approach used
to address severe degenerative
arthritis. Step four is stopping the
leak. Providing premium raw materials is
useless if you continue to subject the
system to metabolic stress. This
illustrates the futility of building
while simultaneously destroying. You
cannot repair a house while the
foundation is being undermined. This
requires an immediate halt to toxic
inputs, specifically fried fats,
processed sugars, and the standard
American diet. Physical recovery remains
impossible if the intake of inflammatory
toxins outpaces your body's ability to
lay down new connective rebar. The fifth
and final requirement for this protocol
is neurological. The body suspends
tissue rebuilding when stuck in a
sympathetic emergency mode, blocking
nutrients from entering the matrix.
Repair only occurs when shifting into a
parasympathetic state, rest and digest.
This is the exclusive environment where
connective repair is permitted.
You can force the body into the state
through mechanical actions, like deep
diaphragmatic breathing, targeted
gratitude, and prayer.
Regulating your thoughts gives the
biological machinery the necessary
permission to divert energy away from
defense and toward healing.
Without this neurological signal, even a
perfect diet and supplement protocol
will remain dormant and unused by your
cells.
The matrix reconstruction protocol is
complete. These five pillars, vitamin C,
polysaccharides, structural proteins,
toxin removal, and a regulated nervous
system, rebuild the body.
The human body is a regenerating machine
designed to renew itself continually.
Healing is your body's default nature,
the moment it is provided with the
correct raw materials and relieved of
metabolic stress.
You can move past the fear of your
symptoms.
By beginning the mechanical
reconstruction protocol today, you can
take back control of your internal
matrix.
>> Okay, folks. So, um
thanks for hanging out. I'm going to
now, uh and there's only a few of us
who have stuck it out till the end. Uh
we are now going to premiere
our newest video. Hopefully, you like
it. Give us some comments.
>> A diagnosis of ALS or severe muscle
wasting is often treated as an
inescapable genetic sentence. The
prevailing medical view is that your
body has simply decided to fail, and
there is no intervention capable of
stopping the decline.
When we view these conditions as a
systemic metabolic breakdown, the focus
shifts from a mysterious destiny to a
mechanical reality.
We stop looking for curses and start
looking for failures in the body's
self-repair systems.
Pharmacist Ben Fuchs describes human
health as a constant balancing act on a
biological seesaw. On one side is
anabolism, building tissue. On the
other, catabolism, breaking it down.
In extreme muscle wasting, that seesaw
violently snaps. The body becomes
trapped in runaway catabolism. It's a
terrifying reality. Your body is
actively consuming its muscle tissue,
literally eating itself faster than it
can patch the damage and rebuild. You
cannot out-medicate this state of decay.
To actually halt the decline, you have
to answer the root question. What
triggered the body to attack its own
tissue in the first place?
There is a core principle in holistic
health. Where you see the problem is
almost never where the problem begins.
To understand dying muscles in the
limbs, we have to trace the
physiological forensics backward,
straight to the digestive system.
When you consume highly inflammatory
foods like processed fats and refined
sugars, they damage the delicate lining
of your intestines.
Over time, these irritants punch
microscopic holes in that barrier, a
condition known as leaky gut.
Instead of absorbing nutrients, your
compromised gut allows a flood of
bacterial debris and undigested food
particles to leak directly into your
bloodstream.
This debris turns the blood thick and
toxic, a state pharmacist Ben calls
dirty blood. To protect your vital
organs from this contamination, your
body shunts this debris toward the
periphery, the connective tissues and
limbs. Simultaneously, the blood
thickens in an immune response to trap
the toxins. This sluggish,
hypercoagulable blood can no longer
navigate the microscopic capillaries
that feed your cells, leaving the
muscles suffocating and functionally
starving. Bathed in this acidic,
oxygen-depleted environment, the muscle
tissue reaches a breaking point.
Individual cells begin to die, and as
Ben describes it, they literally
explode, spewing their internal enzymes
and acids directly into the surrounding
tissue. This cell explosion creates a
vicious cycle. The debris from the
ruptured cells floods the kidneys,
straining your primary filters, and
triggering massive inflammation that
drives the body into even more
aggressive muscle catabolism. You cannot
rebuild a house in the middle of a
hurricane. Before any repair can begin,
you must execute an emergency triage
response, and completely cut off the
stream of toxicity. The fastest way to
do that is a 24-to-48-hour
water fast. By stopping the intake of
food entirely, you stop the influx of
toxins, and give your hyperactive immune
system and overworked digestive tract a
mandatory reset. When you resume eating,
the guesswork has to end. You must keep
a strict food diary to track how your
body responds to every meal, allowing
you to identify and permanently
eliminate the specific triggers causing
your inflammation.
With the toxic influx stopped, you have
to clean up the wreckage in the blood.
This requires taking systemic enzymes,
specifically ultimate enzymes, on a
completely empty stomach. Because there
is no food in the stomach to digest,
these enzymes pass directly into the
bloodstream. They act like a Roto-Rooter
for the vascular system, seeking out and
dissolving the inflammatory proteins and
dead cellular debris clogging the blood
flow.
By sealing the gut, neutralizing the
blood debris, and aggressively flushing
the kidneys with water and plant-derived
minerals, the emergency is contained.
The body is finally prepared for the
rebuilding phase.
Now you transition to the offensive
strategy. To restore the atrophied
limbs, you have to move the biological
seesaw out of breakdown and back into
anabolism.
Muscles are composed almost entirely of
protein. Synthesizing new muscle fibers
is chemically impossible if your body
lacks the exact raw materials required
to build them.
You must saturate your system with
branched-chain amino acids and whey
protein. These are the building blocks
that trigger muscle repair and growth
without placing a heavy metabolic burden
on your digestive system.
Creatine is also a necessary addition
for any condition involving muscle
wasting.
It provides the essential energy to
protect fragile recovering muscle tissue
while simultaneously supporting
neurological health.
But muscle fibers do not exist in a
vacuum. They require a physical
structural matrix, the body's internal
scaffolding, to attach and anchor
themselves to.
The healthy bone and joint pack,
GlucoGel Caps, and collagen peptides
provide the critical goo and fibers
necessary to rebuild the entire physical
framework that holds the muscles in
place.
A rebuilt structure and new muscle
fibers provide the potential for
movement, but the nerves provide the
command. Without a healthy electrical
signal, the muscles remain dormant. To
restore the grid, you have to saturate
the cells with all 90 essential
nutrients, focusing specifically on
those that facilitate electrical nerve
conduction.
This brings us to thiamine or vitamin
B1. Historical biochemical discoveries
proved that severe nerve pain and the
wooden legs of peripheral neuropathy
were directly reversed by reintroducing
this vitamin to the diet. Thiamine
restores the electrical conduction
required for nerves to function. It
allows signals from the brain to travel
without interruption and successfully
fire the muscle fibers. This is the
protocol's goal. Clean blood, rebuilt
structure, and restored electrical
signals working together in perfect
coordination.
A diagnosis of severe muscle wasting is
not a mandate for passive decline.
By controlling the gut, clearing the
blood, and feeding the growth pathways,
patients have the agency to redirect
their metabolism from active breakdown
towards structural renewal.
>> All right, folks, and that is
our show for tonight. I really thank you
all for being here, and thank you for
being part of team, and we will see you
next time.